Multiplica -4x al cuadrado por
3x cuadrada más 25x -7 ¿Ok? Quieren que multipliquemos un monomio por un polinomio.
Entonces tenemos que utilizar la ley
distributiva para multiplicar pues, este monomío, por cada uno de los monomios de acá, por cada uno de los términos.
Entonces hay que multiplicar este por este, luego este por este,
este por este y al final sumar, vamos a ver ¿Cuánto nos queda al hacer esas operaciones? Déjame empezar con este color verde.
Primero tenemos que hacer -4x cuadrada por 3x cuadrada, -4x cuadrada
por 3x cuadrada,
¡Va! Y ahora tenemos que sumar lo que nos queda
con 25x o sea -4x cuadrada, -4 x cuadrada por 25x, 25x
y finalmente tenemos que sumar -4x cuadrada por -7, entonces lo pongo aquí
- 4x cuadrada por -7 ¿Muy bien? Vamos a ver cuánto es esto, déjame hacer un paso intermedio.
Probablemente no lo tengas que hacer, después cuando tengas un poco de práctica pero, ahorita es bueno hacerlo.
Entonces voy a juntar los números aquí me queda -4
- 4 por 3
-4 por 3 por "x" cuadrada por "x" cuadrada, simplemente use la propiedad conmutativa.
Esto de aquí ¿Cuánto es? Esto es
o sea -4 por 3 es -12, "x" cuadrada por "x" cuadrada tiene la misma base, sumamos los exponentes
2 más 2 es 4, -12x a la cuarta ¿Muy bien? y a eso tenemos que sumar
este producto, déjame ponerlo así.
Entonces -4 por 25
por "x" cuadrada por "x", otra vez junte los números a la izquierda y las variables a la derecha
-4 por 25 es -100
-100 y "x" cuadrada por "x" pues este "x" lo podemos pensar como "x" a la 1
entonces es "x" al cubo ¿Verdad? Se suman los exponentes y finalmente vamos a ver aquí que nos queda,
nos queda -4
-4 por -7 por "x" al cuadrado y eso de ahí cuánto es,
eso de ahí es pues -4 por -7 es 28, entonces es más 28
por "x" al cuadrado.
Muy bien y con esto terminamos. Ahorita ya no hay que simplificar nada,
los exponentes son distintos entonces no podemos hacer nada más y así lo dejamos.